welcome everyone to part one of
nightmare has to add to the coerce I
didn't stay wrong I get the feeling this
is gonna be like fear but actually scary
I have tried fear I didn't think it was
scary at all
I'm not sure why it was like daylight I
guess that's why so I hope this will be
a more successful let's play depends on
me if it's scary or not because I want
to be scared nice that is a fun of this
genre I'm not gonna talk too much
whatever I was going to play just seen
I'll probably do that after this one and
playing hard because I'm badass yeah
freakin badass I don't think it'll be
that difficult I think we're gonna go
let's freakin do this
oh that's a good sound crash already
know alright prologue Prague Lee I
thought it said what chapter 1 chapter 2
I reckon
Rudy are you gonna play rakia I will
equate I will stream it I think and I
forgot that was my skype by the way I
think I forgot I'm sorry I'm not perfect
loading loading loading there is lack of
commentary I guess he can say hello to
my face I love that are you doing babe
yeah so
I try to think of pickup lines but I
don't know any she's the one in English
shy kicks it's tirado's mhm yes very
slow loading two minutes and I haven't
done anything
yeah two minutes and ten seconds still
haven't done anything
Wow really really really guys sorry that
was too much
I hope the resolution is correct I
forgot about that
line were two miles will start after
finishing oh I really want to play the
prologue though
I'm scared
see I love the half-life 2 engine it's
the best it's the best the best z
business but oh this is creepy
already
am i doing it anyway ah [ __ ] at this
freaking what all about this sounds so
creepy
I need to take a whiz what
why is our period everywhere when I play
scary games
that's my innocence see if I remember
how to pick stuff up yeah I throw I
forgot yeah all right sensitivity is
bananas it's long oh yeah I remember
I've sinned this real quick I need to
break that
I need fix something up to break it what
not us distinguishable whipping in this
game I have to say oh [ __ ] there's this
alcohol it's like my house what no
alcohol jokes I'm sorry
it's flashlights no I don't have a
flashlight maybe I forgot it in the car
I'm out of gas is that oh we crash see
then Yin is still learning that me was a
problem okay we totally for dinner
forget anything
Oh weekend morning I'm lost I'm lost too
I'll screw up it's like a castle house
ah whoa
whoa
uh-huh oh my god freaking bicycle I hear
we all snap oh no no no I don't want an
axe I don't huh next oh [ __ ] I've done
it I look pretty badass no problem
monsters you got it bring it on my ass
finally have a something better than a
friggin pickaxe to defend myself bring
it bring it bring it bring it
hmm I have flashlights
like sound like a spanking something or
we can just open it
ah come on I told it I totally do that
I'm awesome I want to [ __ ]
hi balls Oh what's with the noises
stop spanking
all period
come on stitch it's not a sham whatever
it's still stupid
ah Oh what the hell are you serious
I gave you spanking with African facts
that brought that night to question a
here's a break already
Jesus Christ I guess we can use
something it up for help
yeah that should be enough yeah better
freakin open what the balls you're so
sick stop being so freaking delicious
oh dude that's strong in so many levels
I why am I still going into this
building what why makes no [ __ ] sense
I would've Oh No
Oh Oh God oh my god can efficient yes
it's been what oh my god
nope freakin nope everywhere
alright let's rig the hell out of it
I don't want to do that again let's have
the gun ready oh my god oh whether the
Bucks go it was tall don't know Oh are
we really doing this
I played fear for like two freaking
hours I was I didn't jump once and then
two freakin minutes oh my god oh my god
okay whatever is something it's a penis
monster actually wasn't I confirmed the
kill like a gazillion times it makes
them [ __ ] self bring it
actually I died so [ __ ] quickly [ __ ]
you [ __ ] Oh actually
monster oh good
oh yeah you better be dead ah
a problem my car need to get out
nope
this game has no britain all over it no
big freakin game nobody know out
everywhere oh my oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] luck
Oh Mike I hate this Cup
isn't that creepy sation I don't wanna
places anymore huh Oh
why not
why frickin not ha
and the freakin sewer okay
oh really alright I'll end it here